what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
byah yes Rob core rings if you guys are
interested in having one um check out
the link in the description it'll go to
patreon.com/crashcourse explained I have
a system there a reward system and it is
the only real way I could figure out to
give the things away equitably uh anyway
uh yeah feel free to check that out so
x-force explained all right I was going
through my list of teams and things
we've talked about we've talked about
New Mutants we've explained New Warriors
we've talked about x-men on a couple
different of a couple different
occasions we've explained the Avengers
I'm pretty sure Justice League all that
stuff we've never explained x-force and
well really now is the only time to ever
do it there'll never be a better time to
explain x-force then with the release of
Deadpool to x-force is a really
intriguing team x-force is a really
interesting situation so a lot of people
would say that x-force made their debut
back in 1990 1991 with x-force vol 1
issue number 1 but that's actually not
true in reality x-force goes all the way
back to New Mutants and the reason why
is because the New Mutants line of
stories are basically designed to kind
of give us this reworking of the x-men
kind of like a new generation of x-men
since the original team was believed to
have been killed or at least the uncanny
x-men were believed to have been killed
and it was just a way to spin out a new
x-men title because the team was so
popular originally it was written by
Chris Claremont then it was taken over
by Louise Simonson and then towards the
end of her writing Rob Liefeld came on
now with regards to Rob Liefeld run and
this is really where the x-force concept
starts to take off you essentially kind
of pick up with like issue number 86 or
so and the reason why was because that's
when Liefeld really came on and actually
became writer for the x-force line of
stories and and the way this worked was
that in the mind of Liefeld you know
looking at the interviews and so on in
the mind of Liefeld the biggest struggle
that the New Mutants had is that they
were reminiscent of an age of comics
that didn't really apply anymore in the
sense that you have the New Mutants is
kind of being teenagers who were under
the watchful eye of Xavier and there
were some great stories early in the
beginning and then you had things like
the New Mutants who were taken over or
really the the x-men universe more or
less the role of Xavier was replaced
with the role of Magneto due to the fact
that Xavier was removed from the
landscape and while those stories worked
the reality is that towards the
of the New Mutants run with issue number
100 sales were waning and they were
basically dropping off but they started
to experience a kind of resurgence as
you got from issue number 86 running up
to issue number 100 and the reason for
this is when Rob Liefeld took over his
idea was amp the team up make them a lot
more hardcore and the reason for that
was because there was there was ample
evidence to indicate that's the
direction people wanted stories to go in
and there were a lot of stories to
indicate that that was the case I mean
you had 1971's the night Gwen Stacy died
you had a Frank Miller's entire
daredevil run you had Batman The Dark
Knight Returns you had Batman year one
you had a lot of stories that were
coming out around that time there were a
lot darker that were far edgier that
we're moving away from kind of like the
wholesome somewhat dark you know interim
period between Stan Lee and Jack Kirby's
original runs on the various Marvel
characters and what basically became the
1990s and so when when when Rob Liefeld
sat down he basically started moving the
story in a direction and made it darker
and made it more hardcore and this came
with the introduction of cable now
originally cable was just super obscure
you didn't know anything about him and
in fact you didn't really learn anything
about cable until May of 1993 really
when his solo series first picked up and
even then like it was a little a little
questionable
um but you know sticking to x-force and
kind of not focusing too much on cable
since we already have a cable explaining
video is sticking the x-force the idea
was taking this new mutants group of
teams and and basically beefing them up
and so over the course of the firt were
really the final nail 14 issues or so
you started getting things like like the
the introduction of Domino the
introduction of like copycat characters
like that the idea that like the team
was basically being moved away from the
whole idea of the New Mutants
functioning under the watchful eye of
Charles Xavier and so when x-force vol 1
issue number one picked up when it was
first released it was it was massive I
mean it was absolutely huge and there
were a couple reasons for why this is
the case the first reason is because it
was a wholly new x-men title x-force
never existed right I mean export you
know x-men vol 2 issue number one the
the highest selling comic book of all
time that was the second volume of the
original Stan Lee and Jack Kirby run but
that was huge because the uncanny x-men
had been made a massive publication by
the writing of Chris Claremont you had
like different iterations of the Avenger
and you've had different Avengers
stories over the years Avengers forever
and new Avengers and things like that
but x-force was brand new there was
nothing like it now there were a few
things that had happened before that in
terms of other publications that have
been released and we'll talk about that
here in a second but because it was so
huge it immediately drew the eye of
everyone it drew the eye of the entire
x-men universe because the reality was
that in the late 80s in the early 90s if
a title had X attached to it it's sold
that's just the way it was because x-men
were so popular so what immediately drew
the eyes of the comic book reader and
then it drew the eyes of the comic book
collector because it was the first issue
of a series that had never existed
before and so like it just exploded in
popularity now for Rob Liefeld worth he
wrote it for about the first nine issues
but really I would say the brains behind
the operation on the original x-force
title was a guy named Fabian de season
now Phoebe anesthesia was a person who
had a long-standing history with Marvel
he'd been writing for quite some time
back in 1989 with Thor 412
editor-in-chief Tom DeFalco launched the
new warriors and it was basically just
kind of like a spin-off group it was
young avengers before Young Avengers
with some new mutants themes thrown in
in terms of like how they related to
each other and so on but it was
relatively popular Fabian de Caesar
wrote it for the first fifty three
issues between 1990 running up to 1994
uh and I mean he did fine it was a it
was a fine job he did things like
writing a venture spotlight let's see he
wrote like a classic x-men which were
basically like the old-school uncanny
x-men stories that were reprinted with a
few more good you know goodies and
tidbits that were thrown in there
weren't originally there to kind of help
flesh those stories out a little bit
more he had a huge standing history in
that and so with regards to his role he
was basically a script or meaning that
he was the one behind the scenes saying
here's the general outline for the
direction the story's gonna go and then
Rob Liefeld would just kind of fill it
in with writing and and art and so on
and so forth but because Rob Liefeld
left in the first nine issues the entire
run of X Factor was I'm sorry x-force
was handed over to Fabian de Caesar and
the reason why this matters is in Marvel
Comics and even DC Comics it was a
long-standing rule that when a creator
created a character that was part and
parcel to that universe that basically
belonged to whoever that publisher was
and there were a few landmark cases that
came out of this for example you had a
Steve Gerber who sued Marvel over Howard
the Duck
you know we talked about that and I
think the Howard the Duck explained
video there were different things like
that that went into the to the whole
idea of how creators were perceived that
led to a lot of frustration because you
had a lot of characters or a lot of
creators who were basically told hey
look you can write Captain America but
only in this small sphere
you can't branch out of that sphere you
can't write him in a way that's not been
normally depicted like a story like
secret Empire never would have happened
in the early 90s even the late 80s so
you would never see a story like that
because adjusting Captain America in
that way was a huge no-no and so what
this did is it led to writers like the
writers and even artists like Alan
Silvestri and Rob Liefeld
and Jim Lee and a lot of Marvel's really
their top talent in the early 90s just
jumping ship they bailed out they went
to image and the rest is history and so
with with the whole idea of x-force
falling to fabien a season in his mind
from what I gather in the interviews he
didn't want to be seen as a poor-man's
Rob Liefeld and Rob Liefeld's writing
style and art had made x-force huge
because you were talking about people
being drawn in such a way that they were
massive in size not only that the big
differentiation between x-force and New
Mutants is that New Mutants were just
kind of like the new x-men and training
x-force was immediately taken over
really like when cable showed up he
immediately took over the team and said
you guys are basically gonna be like a
strike team that's really what you guys
are gonna be you're gonna be my personal
strike team and and they serve that role
well in the sense of they they fought
things like the Mutant Liberation Front
that was led by strife there was a
farmer was at the right I think it was
they felt like a lot of these really
really hardcore militant groups because
the focus of x-force and and the latter
stages of the New Mutants was we're
fighting for mutant rights and we'll do
whatever we have to do to win and it was
it was pretty sadistic you take that and
you bring in elements like you saw new
mutants number 98 with the introduction
of copycat basically a character like
mystique whose powers are far more
advanced you can even copy the powers of
others the introduction of Deadpool you
talk about like all these things that
kind of fold into the beginning of New
Mutants Ansari the beginning of x-force
with Rob Liefeld
and it was a recipe for success but when
Rob Liefeld left all eyes turned to NASA
and when it seems to take over his
immediate response was shift everything
up and so what we got in really within
the first year of the events of x-force
number one is we got a story called
executioner
now in reality executioner saw him
crossed over all the x-men titles so
x-men vol 2 uncanny x-men x-factor
x-force to me it crossed over all of
them and it was essentially bringing in
like these little tidbits of cables
history and so what you ended up
learning is that at some point in the
future cable will have a clone and that
clone will not be hindered by a
techno-organic virus which cable has
that tries to convert his living tissue
into machinery and where cable has to
use his celebrity and telekinesis to
keep that virus from quite literally
eating him alive
strife a dozen and so strife basically
came back in his war against cable which
had been going on for thousands of years
tried to assassinate Professor X and
done all these horrible deeds while
impersonating cable and so the idea was
that cable and an x-force are deemed too
extreme and too dangerous and were just
kind of you know scuttled and locked
away by the rest of the x-men universe
and then the you know the executioner's
song crossover continued on running
until x-force issue number 18 now the
reason why this matters is because what
Fabian a seasoned wanted to do was
rework the team in its entirety in his
image and not continue Liefeld's work
and so when issue number 18 cable was
killed off basically it was his
climactic battle between himself and
strife and they were just thrown into
the timestream and as far as I'm aware
they were never supposed to be seen or
heard from again
and so following that going into the
future of the x-force comics while cable
did return in issue number 25 during
that interim period during that seven
issues miss season basically crafted the
stories in such a way that one the team
immediately broke off from the x-men and
two they went to go try to figure out
who they were and this resonated with a
whole lot of fans because what it did is
it kind of covered this interim period
in fact there's a guy named Bret white
who wrote a really really good article
on Comic Book Resources talking about
this which I'll link down in the
description but to basically because I
really can't say it better than he did
to kind of reiterate his point not a lot
of comic books focus on like well I'll
take that back a lot of comic books
focus on the interim period like where
you have young kids who gain their
powers and they're taken under the wing
of any particular superhero group
they're taken under the wing of the
Avengers in the case of Young Avengers
they're taken under the wing of the
x-men in the case or I guess under
Xavier in the case of any of the x-men
titles you know like like you see that a
lot what you don't see is the interim
period
when they walk away and that's what
x-force underfae be and the seeds that
basically showed us it had the immune of
the x-force essentially saying our
leader is gone but we're not new mutants
anymore we're not little kids we're
gonna go out and forge our own path and
that's what those seven issues focused
on us so Mike cable came back in issue
number 25 everything was totally
different and the story's kind of
gravitated and pushed themselves in a
way where you kind of had this this line
of publications or really like this
overarching plot where cable was trying
to be the Xavier of x-force and they
wouldn't accept it they were like you
can work with us but you're not we're
not gonna work for you like this that's
the way that's this whole thing
transpires there are a lot of other plot
threads that went in there in terms of
things like you know like hoppy cat and
Domino and and what you know what
Deadpool really was Deadpool had a lot
of appearances and the old and the early
x4 stories uh but for favorite seasons
run these theme is basically concluded
with issue number 43 when he walked away
from the title in 1995 and so after
Fabian of Cesar stopped writing the
series was taken over by Jeff float and
really even after Jeff flow we was taken
over by by a handful of other people
like Warren Ellis the whole idea was
looking at this whole situation the goal
was to move the stories in a way where
they could built on what Fabian a Caesar
had done but each writer could
essentially make it their own that's the
nature of comics just kind of the way
those things work the problem with this
was that Marvel by the time to seize a
left in 1995 and then you had Jeph Loeb
who took over and then you had Warren
Ellis who took over and really
yeah I'd say Warren Ellis who took over
um or no you I think you had you had
John Moore who took over before before
Warren Ellis did so Jeph Loeb John Moore
and then Warren Ellis I think regardless
of what order it goes in the fact
remains you basically ran into a
situation where you had Marvel in the
midst of the comic bust and the reason
why this matters is because when Marvel
was looking at this idea of potentially
going bankrupt because you know fans
almost destroyed the comic book market
Marvel didn't really have the ability to
devote full time resources to comics
that weren't necessarily guaranteed to
sell and while x-force was initially
huge when it first picked up over the
course of Fabian deceases run where
artists like Greg Capullo had like
amazing you know did like an amazing job
on the title you had guys like Tony
Daniel whose art was you know kind of
media you know moderately receive and
then you had a few
after that but the sales started to go
down and as the sales started to go down
Marvel started to kind of push in riders
who had a name for themselves like Jeff
lobe and then start pushing in newer
riders and devoting better riders to
other publications it's one of the same
reasons why you've got Marvel Knights
like we've talked about that before
Jimmy paliotta Joe Quesada launched
Marvel Knights I'm sorry launched event
publications basically a way for Marvel
to publish stories on superheroes at a
cheaper rate for the ones who weren't
guaranteed to sell daredevil Punisher
different things like that
this century Robert Reynolds and so on
and so forth and so really running up
until about probably bout 2001 for the
most part Manabe blim say 2001 yeah
probably bout 2001 for the most part
x-force just kind of began to
consistently drop off and the whole
series is basically cancelled and
relaunched with issue number 115 now the
relaunch was really more of like a
miniseries and then after that the whole
series was restarted all over again but
it was done under the writing of a guy
named Peter Milligan the problem with
Peter Milligan's riding and the problem
that a lot of fans had with it was
people looked at x-force and they saw it
as like this high-octane super fast
paced set of events where you had things
popping off all the time you had guys
like GW bridge and you had shatter star
and you had all these these these just
super amped up characters who were
impossibly large and different things
like that I mean now seiza and Greg
Capullo kind of fixed that by drawing
them in a more proportioned scale as
opposed to Rob Liefeld who basically
made cable like 7 feet tall and 500
pounds of just and like like 0% body fat
who made him just like this massive guy
the fact remains people didn't really
want to see what Peter Milligan had it
was interesting for a little bit but
Peter Milligan really kind of reworked
the team into the situation where it was
more of like a free-floating kind of you
know well you know figure out your life
and enjoy things and you know whatever
happens happens and in truth like like
people weren't really on board with that
now the reason why that worked for what
it was or at least the reason why
muffled went with that is because in
2001 following the departure of really
to say in 2004 when in 2001 following
the departure of RAM Morrison Marvel had
something called x-men reload and x-men
reload was basically looking at the
entire landscape of the x-men comics and
then just relaunching them that was the
whole idea we've talked about that
before right like you know Joe Quesada
came in as editor-in-chief and said okay
what you guys have been doing for the
last ten years is what almost made you
bankrupt so we're gonna fix this and so
he went through and literally just sort
of cutting a swath through everything
Peter Parker lost the marriage to Mary
Jane 98% of the mutant population lost
their powers
The Avengers broke up I mean it was it
was a massive undertaking in terms of
like trying to make it all work and and
and it was fine I mean honestly I liked
a lot of what came out of it but the
fact remains here that under Peter
Milligan's writing the team just didn't
really resonate with fans and a lot of
that was because when joke has sought it
sat down and said what are we going to
reinvigorate what are we not gonna
reinvigorate x-force was on the back
burner because it hadn't really been
popular since they'd be in this season
left and so following this what Marvel
did is in in light of the xmin reload
the goal was to rework the entirety of
the x-men mythos and so for the most
part x-force kind of took a back burner
for like six years it was gone for a
long time you had a miniseries in there
somewhere but basically it was gone so
this segwayed into the post house of M
landscape going into Messiah Complex in
Messiah War with Craig Kyle and Chris
Joss Ron which I really kind of
considered to be x-force vol 3 although
some people call it x-force vol 2 taking
into account the miniseries but in terms
of the ongoing x4 series its vol 2 but
the idea of Craig Connell and Chris Yost
it was amazing because what their
x-force team did is it really for the
first time broke the team away from
cable and said this is a standalone
x-men team and so what it did is I'm
sorry yeah what it did is it basically
maintained the charter of the original
x-force and being like a black ops
strike force but it did it without cable
and so what had happened here is
following the events of House of M he
went into a story called Messiah Complex
and then a story called Messiah war and
Messiah Complex was basically the birth
of the first mutant after 98% of the
mutant population launched their powers
and it was a mad dash for this for this
new mutant who was born you ended up
finding out that cable was tasked with
getting the mutant out of there and the
request was made by Charles Xavier but
because of the fact that this mutant was
born after the events of house of M you
had various groups out there who wanted
to destroy it
because they believed that it was the
harbinger of like the resurgence in
mutant population you had groups out
there who wanted to kidnap it and use it
for experimentation find a way to
duplicate its powers creating more
mutant powers and then you had the x-men
who wanted to capture it so they could
keep it safe because they believed that
like it was going to be the the second
rise of
the mutant population and things were
going to return to the way they were
before Scarlet Witch screwed everything
up and so coming out of that when it was
learned by Cyclops that cable had
kidnapped the I'm sorry the cable had
taken the baby and basically was jumping
through the timestream he reformed
x-force using Wolverine x-23
nuts I Locke I don't think she came into
a Rick Remender run but maybe she did
anyway they they basically reworked the
team and the idea was for the first
really I think it was about 28 issues
that it ran the idea was you guys are
going to your initial launch of the team
it was gonna be to jump into the future
and fine cable get the baby and bring it
back which they successfully did
following that because the return of
x-force was so popular and because the
story was so well written Marvel
continued it on as long as they could
the issue with this is that they did
this in the midst of reworking the x-men
constantly and so it was only ever going
to be a short-lived series because
things change all the time and so what
ended up happening is that an issue
issue number 28 by the time that issue
came along the x-force brand had kind of
been expanded on you know from its
original intention with regards to the
launch of volume 3 and it turned into be
a black ops team be a strike force team
and serve the purpose of making sure
that one nobody knows you exist and to
going through and doing whatever you
need to do in order to make sure that
like no other members of the mutant
population or harmed and again like a
team led by Wolverine was massively
popular but following this and going
into the launch of a really 2010 and the
start of Marvel now that was a
conclusion of joke Asada's whole ten
year you know decade-long work to
reinvigorate Marvel and so where you had
a lot of stories that went in between
where you had things like fear itself
where everybody gets a hammer of Thor
and you had like all these crazy
situations that went on what you ended
up getting was something called the
Heroic Age and the heroic age was
essentially sitting down and saying okay
so we had Civil War where Captain
America and Iron Man fought over
superhuman Registration the bad guys one
registration went through that led to
the revelation of secret invasion where
the shape-shifting scroll race had
replaced all you know a huge chunk of
the superhero community if not all of it
and a pretty good chunk of humanity that
led into the events of Dark Reign where
after Civil War Iron Man was director of
shield but didn't know Secret Invasion
had happened and so they booted him out
saying
inept norman osborn the green goblin
became director of shield disbanded it
tried to conquer the world and that led
to the to the defeat of Norman Osborn
following dark rain and so the heroic
age was kind of Marvel saying now we're
getting back to the Age of Heroes as you
know them and so it was like well we've
just rediscovered what it means to be
Avengers and so on and so forth and
different things like that and for the
for the x-force team under Rick Remender
it was kind of reworking it and making
things work again but x-force was rooted
and based in a darker team and so
because of that while everything else
was everybody rediscovering their roles
as heroes the idea of Rick Remender was
making you keep them dark keep them
toned down and so on the first story arc
they basically assassinate the character
that will become apocalypse like phantom
X a member of x-force just shoots him
and that said the story's kind of
remained in that path and they stayed
relatively dark when you go after that
when he went after Rick Remender run it
kind of broke off into a couple of
different titles you had cable and
x-force and then uncanny x-force which
was the name of the Rick Remender run
uncanny x-force uh and and it served as
purpose for what it was the problem is
that by this point in time and
population our popularity in the x-men
in terms of Marvel Comics it was kind of
running stagnant and it actually has for
quite some time and all-new
all-different marvel had dropped off
almost in its entirety because a lot of
people didn't like the direction that
Marvel was going in because they were
kind of like scuttling back the the
x-men and trying to replace him with the
Inhumans which no one liked it because
no one cares about the Inhumans because
the Inhumans don't even care about the
Inhumans and so because of that like
like what you ended up having was an
x-force team that was reminiscent of the
1990s in terms of themes but none of the
stories were compelling as interesting
as they were Dennis hopeless Sam
Humphreys who were writing you know uh
cable and cable in the ex I'm sorry
cable and x-force and uncanny x-force
respectively uh it was a story it was a
line of comics that existed but it just
didn't really work and Marvel had try to
rework two things on several occasions
for example after Peter Milligan's run
it was revamped and turned into
ecstatics which was kind of weird it was
listed like a reality TV show version of
x-force Marvel II try to rework the team
over the years and make it more
interesting in an effort to try to kind
of capture the fabien a Caesar run but
the reality the situation is that the
1990s x-force team was lightning in a
bottle and for what I see with Deadpool
2 it's basically gonna be Fabian
x-force it's really what it looks like
it's gonna be the roster may have
changed a little bit but that's
basically what it's gonna be it's it's
essentially gonna be that version of the
team which is good because that's the
one that people are most well well aware
of I mean in truth
I'd say the x-force team that you see in
Deadpool 2 is gonna be a combination of
the late end of yeah of Rob Liefeld New
Mutants going into like the early launch
of x-force kind of that in-between
period right there it's basically the
version of the team that you're gonna
see which in reality is still kind of
the same team it doesn't really change
but still I mean it looks like it'll be
awesome I mean that's that's kind of
what I'm hoping for here is it'll give
us a it'll it'll at least for me anyway
sitting down and looking at Deadpool 2
it'll remind me of the early 90s and
really like the mid-90s x-force run but
at the same time also also something a
you know offer something a little bit
refreshing and kind of give us a new
take but nonetheless hopefully this
helped you guys out to understand the
nature of x-force and and why it exists
and the purpose it serves if you are new
here to comments explain make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]